hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay this is the
first official episode where I'm back on
the 15-minute schedule so sorry I had to
go through all that backlog and sorry I
got confused with the the outro I
totally didn't mean to do that
that's my minecraft after that okay
alright so we got the fuse and we need
to go back to the subway plug it in and
get out of y'all but I'm kind of kind of
forgotten where I am now this looks
familiar huh yeah where the heck am i I
don't even remember where I am like
seriously I've got the fuse in my
inventory I'm not the right safe spot
it's just that I'm at a complete loss of
where I am oh did I go backwards am i
stupid
am I am i stupid quite possible yeah
I'm like I haven't know where I left off
I'm confused that's all get up her this
way Dory's damn cannot open it
hmm ain't that a problem I know where
the subway isn't just
oh it's snowing okay
okay where's yeah okay here we go oh the
long way idiot
that's nice touch smelly smelly stuff
okay go down here to this subway down to
the subway plug-in diffuse looting there
did you
yeah make it progress okay
who's out there I'm ready foot huh
reach Hansen square through Saxon Avenue
one shot one shot you doors are broken
doors don't become broken you pull them
open like a man walk them Oh
save it
VPI I got rid of that gun probably
should it was probably one of the best
guns available or some crap like that
was that I you something
Wow
what's that
locked with an electric okay huge ah
hello hello lady who's shotgun impotent
to say the least
I still hear some
[Music]
oh it's a reverse tree of death okay so
obviously can't go that way maybe I can
get that train to like Ram it and
destroy it
that's probably okay it's awfully bright
down here I wonder how long that'll last
the mod team yeah
stop doing that
what's up no no strings can't get me to
okay someone said that if I pull out my
phone I can
yeah-ha punch the punch with my food
come on die oh you want to die did you
just stab yourself in the fist
reload my gun oh who also who all boom
oh hello toilet remember AIDS I didn't
forget aids to remind me what's in here
oh this don't look good
ha dark no no no lady you you will die
you will die lady oh what the
but one no shotgun to the face
not today lady oh you're not so scary
how about a face shot ha ha ha ha
drop get out of here oh man still don't
like you
gosh okay o'clock good because I can get
my phone and gun out they had it woo
don't budge anymore ladies huh Rindge
syringe of what syringe of AIDS
I like these always ah found you oh you
still ugly honk
no no suicidal influence on me no nope
nope nope you're late to be here go on
here Harry oh okay Oh some sort of
control room um switch how's it just a
little switch all these buttons no just
a switch anyone else huh is that blood
spare from that lady what's down here
Chuck again who's that huh haha nope
dive is scary
can I get three Doors won't budge then
not budge
oh what the
timer or something bull honkey gah
alright I better hurry up
nice subtle way of telling me I'm too
slow fine whatever
let it be on a timer that's this
inconvenience I'll play your game you
rolled okay and now we run like the
dickens run run run on fungi run like
there's monsters behind you like a
little baby you are okay I don't have
much run juice but it was plenty time I
like stick around
come on get through the damn thing geez
all right let's go okay I shouldn't have
sprinted in the first place if I was
gonna go this you better let me get
there and die you better let me
will be very upset huh there we go there
we go here we go here we go here we go
bunk yeah barely in time okay no battery
[Music]
low battery that's that's not good oh
boy
it's not [ __ ] smash it hit hit yeah get
it get it all smoosh
ha
cilix kind of there I should probably
stop using that okay was this different
nothing whoa what was that huh sir here
okay my battery is low on my phone
that's probably very bad maybe it's
about time I got an actual flashlight
maybe how about that
no would that be too smart is my brain
too big for that idea
oh it's a bed monster all you wet the
bed
with your blood that sounds alright I'm
ignoring you bad guy you do punk who's
the man this guy all right who wants
some say point
there we go well also you may have
noticed that the saved points are kind
of far away from each other it's what's
gonna happen is um III record an advance
but with my new schedule I'm not gonna
record an advance so much so that way I
can keep up to date with what you are
asking me to do let me throw that
probably was a bad idea why did I
probably sway stood that but whatever
what the hell oh that's an ominous red
glow all right oh gosh it's dark my
phone's out of hours old good golly Oh
where I mini Christmas okay here we go I
don't like this ha ha you drop the bear
oh no oh no oh no please be the correct
way out don't like don't like do not
like
hello hello hello hello okay alright
another flare okay I needed that what
hello what's up there anything down here
is the ground sound so I should have
expected that I'm an idiot
okay I'm back here balderdash okay
whatever I'm just gonna go down there's
obviously nothing down there yet so just
intended to freak me out a bit
maybe Oh why'd they take my battery away
from me yeah yeah yeah yeah here out of
here oh I think here stay out stay out
y'all y'all are [ __ ] I don't like
any of you maybe you're not one I do not
like I think I wanna go up the ladder
it's it's a safety hazard to have
tunnels without adequate lighting
someone could trip and get hurt
okay I'm willing to bet that I can't get
that Glock magazine comeback so I won't
try it again oh man this guy is so bad
it's printing there's that train should
have known who's driving the train they
helped me stop all it's dark shotgun
that door I know I know I know I know
oh why am I going up towards the noise
[Music]
hey what's through here here I go
through here
Oh
oh is that out of unlock secret items
what what
how to unlock secret items what the hell
is that mean
man don't mess with me
that's what we found
the gun Glock magazine
Oh No
oh boy
ah why did I sprint bad choices sprint
there hey what do I do now your bottom
down there nope it would be a bad idea
to fall and I just placed it oh I don't
go down I go up or maybe if I'm wrong
yeah I do I do go I go up is that where
I was I'm an idiot okay
oh I don't like this guy's Wow alright
guys I gotta cut here thank you guys so
much for watching as always I'll see you
in the next part bye bye